what are you excited about right now in  terms of deep learning sighted about  this machine translation even though I  myself haven't made any direct  contribution to it some of my students  are doing it I think over the fairly  short term we're going to get much  better translators yeah I am excited for  things like understanding documents I  think there's going to be huge progress  there over the next five to ten years  instead of giving Google some words and  they they'll find you all the documents  have those words in you give Google some  themes and it'll find the documents that  are saying that even if they're saying  it in different words and so you're  going to be able to search for documents  by what it is the documents are claiming  independent whatever the works are that  would be kind of useful  you